On nous dit que l’Univers est en expansion.
Bon, ok, mais en expansion dans quoi ? Cette
question là revient régulièrement chaque
fois que je parle d’expansion de l’Univers
ou du Big-Bang en général. On me demande
aussi : où est le centre de l’Univers ? où
a eu lieu le Big-Bang ? dans quoi l’espace-temps
est-il courbé ? Est-ce que notre corps aussi
on est en expansion ?
Pour répondre à toutes ces questions que
vous me posez souvent, j’ai décidé de
faire une sorte de petite FAQ de l’expansion
de l’Univers, et dans cette vidéo je vais
donc essayer de clarifier tout ces points.
[jingle]
Commençons par les observations astronomiques.
Si on parle d’expansion de l’Univers,
c’est parce qu’on peut l’observer et
la mesurer. Si on regarde un grand nombre
de galaxies autour de nous, on se rend compte
que quasiment toutes les galaxies s’éloignent
de la nôtre.
Et à première vue ça parait assez improbable
comme situation. Si on vivait dans un simple
univers fixe rempli de galaxies qui bougent,
on s’attendrait à en avoir certaines qui
s’éloignent mais d’autres qui se rapprochent.
Or, on observe que presque toutes s’éloignent
de nous, à plus ou moins grande vitesse.
Une façon de l’expliquer ce serait de dire
que notre galaxie a un truc très particulier,
pour que toutes les autres s’en éloignent.
Comme si on était une sorte de point central
de l’Univers que toutes les galaxies fuiraient.
Ca parait assez peu convaincant comme idée,
il y a des de milliards de galaxies observables,
pourquoi la nôtre en particulier serait spéciale.
D’autant plus qu’il y a un autre élément
troublant : la vitesse à laquelle les autres
galaxies semblent s’éloigner de nous.
[HUBBLE Si on trace un graphique qui donne
la vitesse d’éloignement de différentes
galaxies en fonction de leur distance à nous,
voici ce qu’on obtient. Ici la distance
est en abscisses, on exprime ça en millions
d’années-lumières. Et en ordonnées c’est
la vitesse d’éloignement de chaque galaxie,
en km par seconde.
Et vous voyez que les galaxies les plus lointaines
s’éloignent le plus vite, mais surtout
que la vitesse d’éloignement semble proportionnelle
à la distance. Cette relation de proportionnalité
c’est ce qu’on appelle la loi de Hubble-Lemaître.]
On aurait beaucoup de mal à justifier une
observation de ce genre dans un Univers fixe
rempli de galaxies qui bougent. Il faudrait
vraiment que tout soit parfaitement réglé
pour que ça se produise, et que notre position
dans l’Univers soit vraiment très très
spéciale. Alors qu’au contraire, cette
observation colle parfaitement avec l’idée
d’un univers en train de se dilater.
Si c’est l’Univers qui globalement se
dilate, eh bien ce serait logique que toutes
les galaxies s’éloignent les unes des autres.
La nôtre n’aurait dans ce cas rien de particulier.
Et en plus de ça, un phénomène de dilatation
globale donnerait précisément une relation
de proportionnalité comme celle qu’on a
vu : deux galaxies auraient l’air de s’éloigner
d’autant plus vite qu’elles sont distantes.
Cette idée de dilatation globale de l’Univers
peut sembler étrange, mais en plus de coller
parfaitement aux observations, elle découle
aussi des modèles cosmologiques de l’évolution
de l’Univers, qui nous viennent de la théorie
de la relativité générale.
Si on applique la théorie de la relativité
générale à l’Univers dans son ensemble,
on trouve qu’il est tout à fait plausible
qu’il puisse être en train de se dilater.
On a donc d’un côté une observation qui
semble dire qu’il se dilate, de l’autre
côté une théorie qui prédit que c’est
normal qu’il se dilate; c’est que ça
doit être vrai, même si on a du mal à l’appréhender.
Parce que qu’est-ce que ça veut dire que
l’Univers dans son ensemble se dilate ? Une
illustration qu’on donne souvent pour essayer
d’en s’en faire une image, c’est celle
d’un ballon de baudruche. Supposez que notre
Univers n’ait que deux dimensions, pour
simplifier.
[BALLON Et imaginons que mon Univers ait la
forme de la surface d’un ballon de baudruche.
Je représente les galaxies comme des points
dessinés dessus. Et si je gonfle le ballon,
vous voyez que tous les points s’éloignent
les uns des autres. Et l’éloignement est
d’autant plus rapide que les points sont
distants. Comme ce qu’on observe dans l’Univers.]
Alors cette image est sympa mais elle est
loin d’être parfaite. Déjà, elle ne marche
que pour un monde en 2 dimensions, nous on
vit en 3 dimensions d’espace. Parfois on
donne une autre image, imaginez un cake aux
raisins en train de gonfler au four.
[CAKE Le cake gonfle, c’est comme l’espace-temps
qui se dilate, et tous les raisins se retrouvent
à s’éloigner les uns des autres, emportés
par ce gonflement. Ça nous fait comme une
expansion de l’Univers mais en 3 dimensions.]
A nouveau c’est une image, mais comme pour
le ballon de baudruche, l’illustration a
ses limites. Dans les deux cas, le ballon
et le cake s’étendent, certes, mais dans
un espace 3D préexistant. Le ballon gonfle
dans l’espace 3D, le cake s’étend dans
les parties vides du four qui le contient.
Si on prend trop cette image au sérieux,
on pourrait croire que l’Univers est lui-même
en expansion dans un espace de plus grand
lui qui le contiendrait. Alors que non, ça
n’est pas cela qui se produit, il n’y
a pas a priori d’espace plus grand.
Ce que la cosmologie nous décrit, c’est
un univers en expansion, qui s’étend, qui
se dilate, mais qui ne se dilate dans rien.
Alors je sais, c’est assez compliqué à
imaginer, et pour comprendre ça, on va faire
un détour par une notion importante qui est
la notion de courbure.
Je l’ai mentionné, la cosmologie utilise
les équations de la relativité générale,
cette théorie qui nous décrit la courbure
de l’espace-temps et les équations auxquelles
elle obéit. En particulier, la relativité
générale nous dit que la matière et l’énergie
courbent l’espace-temps. Et l’expansion
de l’Univers peut d’ailleurs être vue
comme une forme de courbure temporelle.
Alors quand on parle d’un truc courbé dans
le langage courant, on visualise souvent ça
: je prend une feuille de papier, et je peux
la déformer, pour lui donner une certaine
courbure. Sauf que là on se retrouve avec
le même problème que tout à l’heure : ma
feuille est un objet à deux dimensions, mais
pour la courber j’ai besoin d’une troisième
dimension, celle de l’espace.
En se représentant la courbure avec une feuille,
on a l’impression que pour courber quelque
chose, il faut disposer d’une dimension
supplémentaire dans laquelle on va courber.
Mais en fait mathématiquement ça n’est
pas nécessaire, c’est même restrictif.
Quand on fait ça, qu’on courbe un objet
au sein d’un espace qui a une dimension
supplémentaire, on appelle ça la courbure
«extrinsèque». Et ça n’est qu’un
cas particulier de courbure, car en mathématique,
on peut aussi parler de courbure «intrinsèque».
La courbure intrinsèque, c’est une façon
plus générale de déformer les objets, et
pour laquelle on n’a pas besoin de faire
appel à une dimension supplémentaire. On
peut décrire la courbure d’un objet sans
avoir besoin de le plonger dans un espace
plus grand pour le déformer. Je vais essayer
de vous l’illustrer avec une image simple.
Tout à l’heure j’ai pris une feuille
de papier et je lui ai appliquée une certaine
courbure, j’aurai pu faire ça avec une
photo par exemple.
[PHOTO Maintenant regardez cette image que
j’ai chargée dans un logiciel de retouche.
Avec les outils du logiciel, le vais appliquer
des déformations, des distorsions à l’image.
Par exemple je peux placer des points et créer
une sorte de grille, et ensuite déplacer
ces points pour déformer mon image.
Je peux faire des trucs un peu tordus comme
ça. Et là ce que je suis en train de faire,
c’est en quelque sorte de courber mon image
initiale.
Et pourtant vous voyez bien que je n’ai
pas de dimension supplémentaire ici. Et même
il est probable que les déformations que
je réalise ne seraient pas faisable simplement
en imprimant ma photo et essayant de la courber
dans l’espace 3D.
Ce que je suis en train de faire là, c’est
de donner une courbure intrinsèque à mon
image. Je la courbe, mais je ne la courbe
dans rien. Ça parait bizarre, et si le mot
courbure est trop connoté pour vous, dîtes
plutôt «déformation» ou «distorsion».]
Pour parler de courbure on n’a pas besoin
de dimension supplémentaire, eh bien c’est
ce genre de courbure intrinsèque dont on
parle en relativité générale. Une façon
de le comprendre, c’est de se dire que la
courbure intrinsèque est une déformation
qui modifie la manière de calculer les distances.
[GRILLE Imaginez une grille, sur laquelle
je vais placer deux points. Et supposez que
je veuille calculer la distance entre ces
deux points. Si je me réfère à ma grille,
vous voyez que mes deux points sont séparés
de 4 cette coordonnée de la grille, et 3
selon l’autre coordonnée verticale.
Pour calculer la distance entre les deux points,
c’est facile, j’ai juste à appliquer
le théorème de Pythagore dans ce triangle
rectangle. La distance que je cherche est
l’hypothénuse du triangle et je trouve
que la distance entre les deux points est
de 5.
Bien imaginez maintenant que je déforme mon
image comme toute à l’heure avec mon logiciel
de retouche. Regardez les coordonnées sur
la grille des deux points sont toujours les
mêmes. Il faut que j’avance de 4 intervalles
de grille le long de cette ligne, puis 3 le
long de celle-ci.
Et pourtant pour avoir la distance physique
entre les deux points, appliquer simplement
le théorème de Pythagore ne marche pas ! Ici
mes deux points sont à une distance plus
grande que tout à l’heure.]
La déformation de l’espace-temps, sa courbure,
on peut la voir comme conséquence d’une
modification du théorème de Pythagore. Dans
un espace intrinsèquement courbé, le théorème
de Pythagore ne marche plus, en tout cas il
faut le modifier. En pratique ça se fait
en ajoutant des coefficients devant le a carré
et b carré. Ces coefficients dépendent de
la position et sont liés à la courbure.
Et la relativité générale nous permet de
calculer en fonction de la matière et de
l’énergie présente. Pour ceux qui connaissent
le terme, ces coefficients c’est ce qu’on
appelle la métrique de l’espace-temps.
Bref, en résumé : pour courber l’Univers,
on n’a pas besoin de le courber «dans»
quelque chose de plus grand. Il est intrinsèquement
courbé, et cette courbure intrinsèque se
manifeste par des déformations dans la façon
de calculer les distance entre les objets.
Et l’Univers en expansion est en quelque
sorte un Univers dans lequel toutes les distances
se dilatent, car les coefficients du théorème
de Pythagore augmentent. Mais sans que l’Univers
soit en expansion «dans» quelque chose.
Une fois qu’on a ça bien en tête, on peut
répondre à quelques autres questions fréquentes
qui portent sur le Big-Bang. Intuitivement,
quand on entend parler pour la première fois
de Big Bang, on s’imagine une sorte d’explosion
très localisée, qui crée une bulle de matière
qui va gonfler.
Sauf que si on se réfère à cette image,
ça pose plein de questions : où a eu lieu
le Big Bang ? où est le centre de l’Univers
où ça s’est produit ? Quelles sont les
galaxies qui sont le plus loin du centre ?
Or vous voyez qu’avec l’image d’un Univers
en dilatation intrinsèque, ces questions
n’ont plus de sens. L’Univers n’a pas
de centre, il ne s’étend dans rien, ce
sont juste les distances qui changent intrinsèquement.
Et donc le Big-Bang a eu lieu partout à la
fois, pas dans un point particulier de l’Univers.
On a d’ailleurs souvent cette question quand
on parle du rayonnement fossile. Il s’agit
d’un rayonnement électromagnétique qui
aurait été émis lors de la formation des
premiers atomes d’hydrogène, environ 380
000 ans après le Big-Bang. On peut encore
observer les reliques de ce rayonnement aujourd’hui,
et il s’agit d’une des confirmations les
plus spectaculaires du modèle du Big-Bang.
Ce rayonnement est observable tout le temps,
partout, et il nous arrive de toutes les directions
à la fois. J’en ai pas mal parlé dans
des vidéos précédentes. Or au moment de
l’émission de ce rayonnement, les distances
dans l’Univers étaient environ 1000 fois
plus petites qu’aujourd’hui.
Si on s’en tient à l’image initiale d’une
explosion localisée, on peut voir ça comme
les reliques d’un feu d’artifice. Mais
si c’était le cas, on ne devrait pas le
voir en permanence, le rayonnement aurait
du faire une perturbation passagère, comme
l’onde sonore de l’explosion du feu d’artifice.
Quand on entend le bruit de l’explosion,
on l’entend une fois, à un moment bien
précis suivant notre distance. Et une fois
que l’onde nous a passée, c’est terminé.
Et donc si le Big Bang s’était produit
quelque part en particulier, ce serait la
même chose avec le rayonnement fossile. On
aurait dû le voir passer une fois, et puis
c’est tout.
Sauf qu’on l’a dit : la dilatation de
l’Univers est intrinsèque et l’émission
du rayonnement fossile a eu lieu partout à
la fois.
[PHOTONS Une image plus correcte serait donc
plutôt celle-ci. Tous les points de l’espace
ont émis du rayonnement dans toutes les directions,
le rayonnement ce sont des photons. Et donc
aujourd’hui, on a en permanence des photons
de ce rayonnement qui se baladent partout
et dans tous les sens.]
Bien voyons maintenant encore quelques questions
fréquemment posées quand on parle de l’expansion
de l’Univers.
[jingle]
Si on regarde le diagramme que je vous ai
montré au début, qui représente la vitesse
d’expansion en fonction de la distance,
on voit que les vitesses peuvent être très
élevées, ça va jusqu’à 40 000 km/s pour
des galaxies situées à environ 2 milliards
d’années lumière.
Et donc si on extrapole, pour des galaxies
qui seraient séparées de plus de 15 milliards
d’années lumières, cette vitesse d’éloignement
serait plus grande que la vitesse de la lumière.
Or des galaxies situées à cette distance,
il y en a.
C’est un peu bizarre, non ? On a tous appris
que rien ne peut aller plus vite que la vitesse
de la lumière ? Eh bien ça n’est pas tout
à fait vrai, quand on dit que «rien»
ne peut dépasser la vitesse de la lumière,
il faut préciser ce qu’on entend.
La «vitesse» d’éloignement dont on
parle ici n’est pas une vitesse au sens
usuel de la relativité. En relativité restreinte,
on parle de vitesse d’un objet matériel
mesurée dans un référentiel local. Or ici
ce sont les distances qui se dilatent, le
référentiel lui-même si vous voulez. Et
donc pour faire simple, la limite de vitesse
ne s’applique pas ici.
[GRILLE Pour le dire de façon plus imagée,
les galaxies sont comme des points sur une
grille et la grille se dilate. Et la limite
de vitesse ne s’applique qu’au mouvement
par rapport à la grille, mais pas à la dilatation
elle-même.]
Quand on regarde le mouvement d’une galaxie,
il faut distinguer le mouvement «dû à
l’expansion» et le mouvement qu’on
appelle «propre». Il y a d’ailleurs
une galaxie pour laquelle la distinction est
important pour nous, c’est la galaxie d’Andromède.
Vous me faites souvent la remarque quand je
dis que toutes les galaxies s’éloignent
les unes des autres : et vous avez raison,
ça n’est pas le cas de la galaxie d’Andromède.
Celle-ci se dirige vers nous et va entrer
en collision avec la nôtre d’ici quelques
milliards d’années.
L’explication c’est que la galaxie d’Andromède
est très proche de nous, 2.5 millions d’années-lumières.
Oui c’est très proche à l’échelle des
galaxies, c’est seulement 25 fois le diamètre
de la voie lactée.
[HUBBLE Dans le diagramme que je vous ai montré
au début, elle se trouve par ici. Donc c’est
une galaxie pour laquelle l’effet d’éloignement
dû à l’expansion est très faible. Tellement
faible que le mouvement «propre» de
la galaxie est bien supérieur, et l’effet
de l’expansion de l’expansion est négligeable.]
Entre la Voie lactée et la Galaxie d’Andromède,
la force de gravité vient largement surpasser
l’effet de l’expansion, et donc elle fonce
sur nous. Ou nous on fonce sur elle, c’est
pareil.
D’ailleurs le cas de cette Galaxie «très
proche de nous», ça me permet d’évoquer
une autre question qu’on me pose souvent
: si tout se dilate dans l’Univers, comment
on fait pour se rendre compte de l’expansion
de l’Univers ? Si un objet se dilate mais
que la règle que j’utilise pour le mesurer
se dilate aussi, on ne devrait se rendre compte
de rien.
Et la raison c’est que non, cette règle
ne se dilate pas. Bon déjà, l’effet d’expansion
à l’échelle des objets terrestres ou même
du système solaire est très très faible.
Mais surtout il existe d’autres forces en
jeu, bien supérieure à l’effet de la dilatation
: la gravité entre les astres, et les forces
électromagnétiques qui assurent les liaisons
au sein des objets.
Prenons une règle métallique, disons en
aluminium pour faire simple. Les atomes d’aluminium
sont arrangés en un cristal, et la distance
entre les atomes dans la maille cristalline
dépend des propriétés de l’aluminium.
C’est environ 0.4 nm, et cette valeur ne
vient pas de nulle part.
C’est une distance d’équilibre des atomes
dans le cristal. Si vous essayez de compresser
le cristal pour rapprocher les atomes, ils
vont se repousser. Et au contraire si vous
tirer sur le cristal pour les éloigner, il
vont se rapprocher. Ca marche comme un ressort,
on peut même modéliser les énergies associées
avec certains calculs de mécanique quantique.
Bien maintenant si par l’effet de l’expansion
de l’Univers vous éloignez deux atomes,
ils se retrouveront dans une position où
la force de liaison va les pousser à se rapprocher.
Et cette force électromagnétique de liaison
est bien supérieure à ce que peut faire
l’expansion de l’Univers à cette échelle.
Donc si on prend une règle, ou n’importe
quel objet dont la cohésion est assurée
par des liaisons chimiques, sa taille ne changera
pas à cause de l’expansion de l’Univers.
Et donc l’Univers est en expansion, mais
pas nous. Donc non ça n’est pas grâce
à l’expansion de l’Univers que vous allez
pouvoir augmenter la taille de votre…
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo, si vous voulez
continuer à en discuter, petite nouveauté,
j’ai créé un serveur Discord communautaire
pour Science étonnante, je vous mets le lien
en description. Abonnez-vous pour ne rien
rater, mettez la cloche et surveillez régulièrement
la chaine car Youtube ne vous notifie plus
systématiquement. Et avec tout ça je vous
dis à très vite pour nouvelle vidéo. A
bientôt. *** POSE MINIATURE ***